well in the last few minutes the health
secretary Steve Barkley has been talking
about the strikes affecting the NHS and
he said that he's Keen to have dialogue
with nursing unions let's have a listen
well I'm Keen to have dialogue with Pat
Collin and the RCN I wrote to them last
week looking at the coming year at the
pressures from inflation and cost of
living how we could work together to
make any settlement more affordable in
terms of looking at what productivity
opportunities there are what efficiency
the opportunities there are because
there's common ground in recognizing
that the NHS is under pressure and we
need to respond to that so I look
forward to talking with the RCN and the
other trade unions to see how do we make
any settlement done through the
independent pay review body more
affordable wherever those productivity
and efficiency opportunities are written
to Pat on that and I hope she engages on
it 10 acceptable is that an acceptable
figure well the the Aussie and actually
turned down an offer in Scotland which
was seven and a half percent and
significantly more than 10 if you look
to the the other things within that
package but the key thing is to look at
the coming year the pay review body will
be looking at the pressure of cost of
living the pressure on inflation the
scope for us to see how we make that
more affordable by working together on
issues of productivity on issues of
efficiency I wrote to Pat about that
last night I hope she engages
constructively on that it's important we
work together to ensure that the
evidence that goes to the independent
pay-per-view body for this coming year
reflects the pressure that the NHS is on
but also what is Affordable to The Wider
economy